[Applaudissements]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce stop
science de la célébration puisque nous
venons de dépasser les 9000 abonnés it's
over night et pour fêter ça quoi de
mieux que de consacrer un épisode
hop un club au pain
oh ben non
zut qu'est ce que c'est que ça bah c'est
le ping ou buzz dès que tu dis n'importe
quoi certains theron métis j'ai dit une
bêtise
bah tu appelles cet animal un pingouin
c'est pas un pingouin c'est un manchot
tangwa et man show c'est parti non sa
part commencé épinglé man show c'est la
même eau
tu as tout péter la machine est contente
pingouin et man show ça n'a rien à voir
il sait quoi les différences alors un
manchot samedi dans l'hémisphère sud est
sa nage est un pingouin sa vie dans
l'hémisphère nord et ça vole pingouins
ça veut et puis quoi encore ah bah non
je t'assure les pingouins et les
manchots sur deux animaux très
différents les manchots sont de la
famille d'espagne ici forme et les
pingouins sont de la famille des cars
adri forme bas se disent les marins tous
les deux non oui mais ce sont des
familles qui se sont différenciés depuis
très longtemps depuis la fin du crétacé
en fait il y à presque 100 millions
d'années les confondre en revient à
confondre une baleine avec un paresseux
géant
c'est à ce point là bah oui et pas qu'un
peu
un fail de proportions épiques et la
confusion a deux origines
premièrement il existe et il n'y a pas
si longtemps de cela des pingouins dans
l'hémisphère nord
et j'insiste dans l'hémisphère nord
uniquement qui ne savaient pas voler et
qui ressemble et superficiellement à des
manchots antarctique et j'insiste bien
superficiellement seulement ça s'appelle
de la convergence évolutive mais ça ne
fera jamais au grand jamais d'un
pingouin un manchot on les appelait des
grands un grain on les rencontre et
depuis le cercle polaire arctique
jusqu'en espagne mais ils se sont
éteints en 1852
mais voilà le plus grand des grands
palois n'a jamais dépassé 5 kg alors que
le plus gros manche baisse jusqu'à 30 kg
ça n'a néanmoins pas empêcher que les
grand pingouin soit confondue avec des
manchots dans le langage courant et à la
deuxième source de confusion c'est un
problème de traduction man show en
anglais s'écrit penguin ah ouais ça
ressemble à mort à pingouins en fait
et ben oui et ça va avec son lot
d'ignominieuses traduction comme le trio
d'intrépides man show
de new york qui deviennent les pingouins
de madagascar
ah ouais c'est complètement con cernant
consternant bon je recommence du coup
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce top science
consacrée à l'évolution des manchots you
les manchots sont l'épreuve ultime de
l'évolution des espèces l'argument
massue que les espèces ne sont pas issus
d'un dessin intelligemment conçu et oui
car qui l'idée ça intelligent dit cahier
des charges
si la nature a été fabriquée de toutes
pièces alors le moins qu'on puisse en
attendre c'est qu'elles soient bien en
fait
explications si tout est intelligemment
conçu alors les oiseaux ont des ailes
pour voler jusque là c'est simple tout
le monde suit maintenant les manchots
les manchots s'ils ont des ailes en tout
point identique à celle des autres
oiseaux les os les muscles les plumes
tout est là donc oui les manchots ont
des ailes mais pas pour voler non
j'espère qu'on ne vous l'apprends pas
mais les manchots évidemment ça ne vole
pas et en matière de cahier des charges
que les des ailes à un manchot qui ne
vole pas c'est à peu près aussi
intelligent que de prendre l'autoroute
en avion tu parles d'un dessein
intelligent
les manchots comme tous les autres
oiseaux qui ne peuvent plus voler sont
la preuve ultime que le créationnisme ne
marche pas le seul moyen d'expliquer que
les manchots et des ailes alors qu'ils
ne peuvent pas voler c'est d'admettre
qu'ils ont évolué à partir d'un oiseau
probablement marins et qui volait ils se
sont ensuite adaptées à la vie marine
perdant leur aptitude au vol mais gagne
en agilité dans l'eau volet demande
beaucoup d'énergie et à la première
occasion de flemmarder les oiseaux ne
rechigne pas à retourner se reposer sur
le haut de plancher des vaches
c'est arrivés des dizaines de fois dans
l'évolution des oiseaux
tenez voici espère onyx un oiseau du
temps des dinosaures tellement marin
qu'il en a perdu ses bras qui sont
prêtes brun pour ce qui est des manchots
ce sont leurs jambes qui se sont
raccourcis augmentant leur
hydrodynamisme leur brasser sont
aplaties se transformant en nageoires
ils ont perdu les poches aérienne de
leurs vertèbres et ont gagné en densité
osseuse ce qui diminue leur flottabilité
et leur permet donc de rester plus
facilement sous l'eau là où les autres
oiseaux ont les au creux ce qui les
oblige à flotter les manchots ont
néanmoins conservé
de leurs ancêtres aérien des poumons
très volumineux et à plusieurs poches
ainsi que cette manière si particulière
de battre des ailes dans l'eau comme
s'ils volaient bonne chance pour
expliquer d'où sortent des caractères
d'oiseaux volant chez une espèce marine
avec un cahier des charges
créationnistes et en plus tout ce petit
scénario est confirmée par le registre
fossile d'un manchot
les plus vieux manchots fossiles sont
originaires de nouvelle zélande et son
vieux de plus de 60 millions d'années
60 millions d'années c'est plus vieux
que le plus ancien des cétacés
ça veut dire qu'on connait mieux
l'évolution des manchots que celle des
baleines et oui avec seulement 53
millions d'années au compteur himalayas
et us le plus vieux c'est assez connus
ne fait pas le poids à dans les fans en
les rares call et du coup figurez vous
que ce très ancien manceau avait
l'alluré d'un cormoran
attention les analyses génétiques ont
montré que les oiseaux volants les plus
proches parents des manchots ne sont pas
les cormorans
mais les procès la réforme comme les
pétrels et les albatros
mais ne nous faites pas dire ce qu'on
n'a pas dit ça veut pas dire que les
albatros où les cormorans sont des
manchots 1
le plus vieux manche veut donc son nom
et wegmann ou ça veut dire oiseaux
marins en maori
il s'agissait d'un oiseau marin aux
ailes encore flexible mais trop petit
pour lui permettre de voler ah oui et
ses jambes étaient déjà très courte
ça devait être un bon nageur oui et la
présence d'un manchot déjà bien adapté à
la vie aquatique si peu de temps après
la fin du règne des dinosaures suggèrent
fortement que les tous premiers manchots
qui ont quitté le monde des erp vivait
déjà au crétacé ce n'est pas si
surprenant puisque des oiseaux tels qu
espère ornis avait déjà pris la voie des
mers bien avant eux
mais la nouvelle zélande n'était que le
début de l'aventuré pour les manchots il
y as entre 48 et 49 millions d'années
une innovation anatomy qui va
révolutionner la vie des manchots en
effet les manchots moderne possède un
système de refroidissement naturel qui
permet de garder leurs ailes froide et
ainsi de ne pas perdre de chaleur par
les extrémités quand ils sont dans l'eau
il s'agit d'un système d'artillerie et
de veynes à contre courant les artères
portant le sens vers l'extrémité de
l'ale laisse échapper de la chaleur qui
est immmédiatement recapter par les
veines qui amène le sang est chauffée au
coeur ce système s'appelle le plexus
sanguins de l'humérus
car les vaisseaux sanguins ils sont si
développés qu'ils laissent des traces
remarquablement visible sur l'os du bras
l'humérus il est ainsi possible de
suivre l'évolution du plexus dans le
registre
aussi à condition de trouver les humérus
de nos animaux et il se trouve que les
premières traces de ce plexus
apparaissent chez les manchots qui
vivait il y à 48 à 49 millions d'années
ces manchots se retrouve partout dans
l'hémisphère sud principalement en
amérique du sud qui deviendra par la
suite un grand centre de diversification
pour les manchots puis en afrique du sud
le plexus humérale à partir d'un réseau
simple d'artères et de vaines a permis
aux manchots de conserver leur chaleur
plus efficacement lors des longues
traversées des océans
d'abord pacifique en direction de
l'amérique puis atlantique pour
rejoindre les côtes africaines
le plexus numéral ça a été un peu le
ticket les manchots pour un tour du
monde c'est grâce à lui qu'aujourd'hui
il ya des manchots depuis les galapagos
jusqu'aux côtes africaines
c'est grâce à lui qu'ils ont pu
rencontrer un si grand succès évolutif
certains tels que paléo 10 passes ou
ical ipes pouvait mesurer près de deux
mètres et peser jusqu'à 100 kg faisant 1
1 du 3 à 4 fois moins lourd manchots
empereurs probablement n'avait-il pas
encore le costard noir et blanc si
classieux des manchots moderne puisque
la peau et les plumes miraculeusement
préservée chez inkayacu un manchot
sud-américains ont montré que son
plumage était gris et brun roux mais
aujourd'hui la plupart des espèces de
manchots sont menacés à cause de la
surpêche du changement climatiques qui
perturbent leur production mais aussi à
cause de la destruction de leur habitat
pour faire des plages ou par des marées
noires
va-t-on laisser la success-story des
manchots prendre fin ainsi l'avenir nous
le dira oh ben non
oh non je protège tu me voir les
manchots continue à évoluer et devenir
des baleines géantes dans le futur ah
oui oui ça pourrait bien arriver mais
pour cela il va falloir des décisions
politiques fortes et sur le long terme
ah bon et est pas cassé celle là bon ben
autant pour moi
[Musique]